i marvel over the top too that's what i  said top two okay no because you said  no i said i'd say he's the fifth best  guard in the league  that's what i said i stand by what but i  say what that stand but you also said  westbrook was better than donovan  and that's where i brought in career  versus this season and i stand by that  too  and i'll say it on national tv and i'll  tweet it on the debate yes he is i'll  say it  i'll be loyal you wouldn't take  westbrook over donovan mitchell right  now i'm not saying what why career i'm  saying this season  i don't go back this season because this  season ain't over yet  d wade how many times have you seen  people have fast starts and then  it happens every year okay so donovan  donovan has shown that he's  a consistent player from his rookie year  up until now i like donovan i really do  but i don't marvel over the fifth best  player i don't do that i marvel over  steph curry  saying wins matter